hello hello everyone and welcome back
to the end game class uh here as
promised i have some fun
end game tactics for you guys to go over
um
as i said in the previous lecture the
idea
for tonight is going to be the idea of
breaking through
right it looks like the opponent in many
of these puzzles
has an impenetrable wall stopping your
pawns from queening
but we're going to look at some common
tactics that allow you to break through
here
and if you guys do well i have a couple
examples from
games of yours truly where uh perhaps a
little bit more practice
in breaking through tactics would have
been uh would have been helpful
but we'll uh we'll see if we we get
there in the end maybe you guys will
just struggle
so much with these tactics that uh we
will never have to get there at all
so this first position is actually from
a game
between a guy messi and glack
which are names that i am vaguely
familiar with
not super specifically familiar with
their entire careers
but anyways in this position it was
white to move
and play and here of course we have even
material on the board
white has advanced a little bit on the
queen side black has advanced in the
center of the board
and it looks as though that black has uh
everything pretty
pretty much under control here so what
do you guys think
and go ahead and and say some moves
but try and give me uh give me the full
line here
try and give me the full line
so yeah you guys are are definitely on
the right track we didn't start off too
difficult here
didn't start off too difficult so
everybody wants to play
bishop takes c6 and everybody is saying
b takes c6 there is the move b6 but
you do have to at least calculate what
happens after the move bishop takes c6
as well right
if bishop takes c6 our opponent is not
forced to capture with the b
pawn b takes c6 is definitely a playable
move or bishop takes
c6 is definitely a legal chess move
and so are you certain that you're
winning that
end game as well
what happens there
what happens there
so yeah of course what happens there is
we just take the bishop
black takes back and the move d5 is
actually going to be enough to win the
game so let's see it in action here of
course
the first line to look at is bishop c6
bc6
and now b6 and as you guys were saying
in the chat room
after takes takes this bishop
unfortunately
is blocked by its own pawn and cannot
stop the pawn
from queening if bishop takes c6
unfortunately this doesn't quite help
black because after captures
captures of course is forced and the
move d5 is again
breaking through the wall of the pawn on
c6
and black is going to be unable to stop
white from
queening after king f6 i think you can
even just
capture on c6 although maybe d6 is a bit
simpler
where a protected pass pawn is always
going to be enough to
win the game in this case so that was an
excellent start
none of you actually said sort of the
trick here which is why not take on c6
with the pawn of course we don't do it
because we want to play b6
but if you see this idea of d5 then
maybe you would just assume
takes takes takes takes and it's all the
same
right of course in this case though it
is not
because after b takes c6 black is able
to
sort of take back on d5 and have his
bishop
still around to uh try and keep the game
going for a bit
so you guys we're off to a good start
here of course bishop takes c6
is the way to go uh in this case
and i wanted to show you guys this
position because it very much is just
the introduction
to the theme here a lot a lot a lot of
times
in these end games they are won or
lost or sometimes these ideas are missed
entirely
because of these types of tactics where
one side is able to sacrifice their
peace
or sacrifice something just in order
to open up the the uh sort of the
pathway to queening for the pawns
let's take a look at another position
now
we have this position here and it is
actually black's
uh turn in this position and
i'll go ahead and flip the board for you
guys actually just so you guys know
this is a game between peter lecko with
the white pieces
and sergey karjakin with the black
pieces and i wanted to ask you guys
what do you think the evaluation of this
position is
what do you think the evaluation of this
endgame
is and
you know come up with a move or two come
up with what you think black's best move
is and
what some possible responses might be
okay everybody's trying to lose the game
everybody saw the last puzzle and
they're like ah it's bishop c3
bishop c3 loses a piece my friends loses
a piece
and white would win the game have to be
careful here have to be careful
don't try to approach these like they're
just tactics puzzles uh
try and approach them like they are
chess games where you have to find the
best move
bishop c3 of course is worth calculating
but you can't
start with the uh the huge tactic finish
every time so what's the evaluation of
the position it's white or sorry it's
black to move here
we're looking from black's perspective
and we're trying to figure out
number one what the evaluation of the
position is and number two
what is sort of the best line i'm
actually going to
shrink that down slightly
so what do we got what do we got
so don't just give me one move give me
give me an example line of course
king f7 is very very natural for black
but
you know how might the play continue
from there
what's black's drawing idea how does
black try to draw here
so yeah you guys are are sort of still
trying to approach it with the
perspective that uh it's just like a
tactics puzzle and black has some forced
win here but
in fact the objective evaluation of the
position is going to be a draw
and if white plays well it's definitely
not
not black who's playing for a win black
only has two pawns left
and black should first and foremost be
thinking how can i stop this e pawn from
queening
so of course king f7 is the best move
and then
for whites uh the simple move is just
going to be to play the move
knight to g5 check and then after
something
like king to f7 or sorry king to e7
i think maybe simplest is the move
knight to
f3 and after knight f3 of course
bishop c3 is still not working
because we could still get here in time
but
what should black do after knight f3
because black
very much is in danger of losing this
chess game uh if black doesn't play well
here uh
the game is going to end with white
winning the game
so you have to find something to do
so black to move here black to move and
try to draw
so a3 of course is forcing the exchange
of the pawns
is that enough to draw i actually i very
much doubt it
i very much doubt it's enough to draw
and so yeah a couple people in the chat
room i am seeing now
the correct suggestion so this a pawn
well
it shouldn't be enough to win for black
because the white knight is
usually in time to stop this pawn is a
very valuable asset
and thanks to this asset black can in
fact play the move g5 here
and this is the drawing idea black needs
to play the move g5 to stop the white
king from invading through the f4 square
and now of course thanks to this tactic
with the a pawn pushing
knight takes g5 would be a bit of a
mistake because bishop c3 is just going
to win the game
we see b takes a3 and now finally
the white knight is too far away to uh
to capture this pawn
so g5 is the fantastic idea to stop
white from invading into the position
and stop white from you know quite
simply winning this chess game
um so kudos to you if you found it uh
now while i was making fun of you guys
for saying bishop c3
unfortunately peter lecko was not
quite um on the ball in this case and
instead played the move
knight to f4 and now of course
black to move and win you guys all
already know the idea
it's bishop c3 uh from f4
the knight is simply too far away to
catch this pawn
if bc3 a3
and there's just no stopping the poor
guy there's no stopping the guy
from becoming a big queen so
knight takes g5 is a draw i don't think
it is
i don't think it is is it a draw it
might be a draw actually
i guess if you come back
i think white wins this more often than
not actually
i think white definitely wins this more
often than not
i i'm pretty sure this position is just
winning
for example king f4 king e6 king here
takes yeah this this is going to be
winning
white can force the the white knight off
of b3 but
i guess it's a bit more complicated than
if white captured there
but black does in fact win in that
position i think anyways
none of that was played in the game we
saw knight f4 and bishop c3
and our tactic does work so like i said
these breaking through tactics
very easy to miss and very often the
decisi
the deciding factor in a lot of these uh
low material end games
okay aryan says easy draw i i very much
disagree there black is black is just
winning but
we will move along to the next tactic
here
uh so this one again is going to be
black to move and of course in this
position it does seem as though black
does have
the upper hand here the knight is
attacked and we have to find some plan
of using these four pawns to break
through against these three
pawns so see what you guys can come up
here
can come up with here for uh for black
more tactics tactics tactics
guys don't just say moves don't just say
moves
okay come up with a line
come up with a line and your line can't
end with you being down a piece
okay your line has to end with you
queening that's that's the new rule
you guys can't just find clever ways to
lose pieces
okay no clever ways to lose pieces
just clever ways to clean your pawn
okay the the object is not to get a past
pawn
and be down a piece the object is to get
a queen
alright let's not confuse the two here
let's not confuse the two
yeah chess king there's a problem with
your line
i won't tell you what the problem is
i'll tell you that there's a problem
and yeah uh once again someone in the
chat room does
does have it does have it
so yeah uh muhammad is seemingly
very much on the case today so if d3
i think the simple move uh c takes d3
might give black you know some chances
here if after knight takes b3 but like
knight c3
knight a4 like the game's definitely not
over here right the game's definitely
not over
not only that i think that white
actually has a much
better move here in the move c4
and all of a sudden you have to be very
very careful if you're playing with the
black pieces here you have to be very
very careful
i think white is just simply winning
this this d-pawn now
uh yeah i think white is simply just
winning this this d-pawn now
but the correct move as some people in
the chat did already see
is the move knight c3 and now we take
advantage of the fact that white's
knight is actually trapped
so knight c3 is coming with a very very
serious threat
and of course uh if white were to
capture this knight
he's lost a crucial defender of the a3
square
and the move a4 is uh going to win the
game here
it's just going to win the game no
matter what white tries to do he's never
going to be in time to stop
this a pawn notably though if um
takes here we should probably just play
a2
and if takes here
now i think a3 would lose the game to
knight to c3 but thankfully we do have
the move c
takes d and we keep this knight boxed
out
just long enough to uh go ahead and
clean our pawn
so good job finding that one guys that
one definitely
one of the harder ones here knight c3
attacking a trapped
knight so let's keep at it let's keep
keep on keeping on here
we have this one which is uh
from a game between uh smithslav
and yastra bra yester yesterbra
yesterbuff yesterbov and so this one of
course is going to be
white to move and uh yeah we have
another minor piece ending
let's see if you guys can find the
proper way
to play this one out for a win for white
what do you guys think
see if you can find a way to play for a
win
and then the harder question
is is that white playing for a win or is
that white
playing for a loss because it's not
immediately clear
this is a free class hello pkt so
everybody and their grandmother sees
that the move b4
is the idea to break through but the
hard question with this puzzle
is is b4 actually worth it
right you're sacrificing a lot of
material
a lot of material here does b4 actually
win
or is that a losing attempt
try and calculate every line here you
guys
guys are a bit asleep at the wheel
sometimes here
losing losing
well give me the losing line then my
goodness winning win
it's tough it's tough
so it might be tempting at first glance
to
uh play the move a5 in this position so
that was the first thing
that i was proud of you guys for not
falling for
because after a5 i think white is
uh in pretty rough shape right you have
to go king d3
you can take here take here and at this
point in time
i think that it's definitely black who
is playing for the advantage and playing
to win this game
uh white has to deal with these two past
pawns and it's true that you broke
through with your c
pawn but uh white i think is is pretty
close to lost here
uh potentially just strictly lost
uh but you guys did find the nice tactic
bishop takes
on c5 and in fact this one is good
enough to win
in this line for white uh if b takes c5
now simply a5 uh b3
we do have to come back to stop this guy
and
white is just in time
to uh to make a queen here and i mean
just in time so if you didn't calculate
all the way out to a8 equals queen then
you could have gone and gotten into some
pretty serious trouble there
but of course the move c takes b4
is potentially playable as well so
what's going on after c takes b4
uh give me a pretty forcing line here
because the moves are
are very very forced there's not a lot
of real variation
for for each side and decide who you
like better
decide who you like better
so chess king says bishop takes b6 b3
king d3 bishop e1
is that what you're saying c5 and we win
interesting claim interesting claim is
there a better move than bishop e1
i'm not sure why bishop b1 was played
not sure why bishop b1 was played
so bishop takes b6 followed by bishop d4
is also potentially interesting
very potentially interesting there so
let's take a look so bishop takes b6 i
think everybody agrees
black should be playing the move b3 now
the question is do you respond to this
move
with king d3 or do you respond with
bishop d4
and choose very very wisely because one
of these moves is advantage to black
and one of these moves is advantage to
white neither of these moves is plus a
billion
not yet not yet
so yeah chess base india has an
interesting question if king d3 what if
king f5 happens
what if king f5
and yeah optic red panda does have
a rather interesting suggestion here
bishop d4 is in fact going to be the
move that grants black the advantage
because the very killer bishop f2
is a tactic available to black and
this puzzle very much is sort of the the
uh
uh poster puzzle for like you know a
huge warning sign
that doesn't make any sense it's a
poster that says look out
don't sacrifice all your pieces
willy-nilly you have to calculate
everything
because if you're not careful if you
just say yeah i take the pawn i go
bishop d4 i'm defending everything c5 c6
c7 c8 i win
then you could very easily run into
these types of tactics
where by giving up material your
opponent also is getting a past pawn
and these tactics are going to start to
be available for
for them as well so
after bishop f2 i do think that black is
simply better
white has to go something like bishop c1
and then from here
i think really anything is playable but
maybe just bishop b6
and in the long run i guess
i can even try and consider running this
way or actually
probably just running up the board is is
going to be a bit simpler
going to be a bit simpler running up the
board and white has
some pretty serious issues in this
position some pretty serious issues
so king d3 now you have to figure out
what happens after the move king f5
so what's happening after king f5 here
okay so really quickly what if bishop b2
chase the pawn with the king uh well
king f5
and if you start taking that guy i start
taking this guy
and going going with this as well even
hands losing a lot of pawns here is
black losing a lot of pawns
as white rather so king d3
king f5 and yeah you guys are on the
right track now
now the move bishop d4 is going to be
good enough because
black no longer has this move bishop f2
because we can simply take it our king
is
in the square of the pawn and white is
winning
what's the best try here for black well
you can potentially play the move b2
and allow white to take this pawn
because you do get the king a little bit
closer to the action here
but of course white is to be preferred
in this end game and i think in the long
run
uh white should should end up winning
although
i think you do have to actually go
bishop bishop c3 so that you can take
this guy
and yeah definitely not the easiest end
game of all time
in fact is white even winning anymore am
i doing something wrong here
yeah maybe we should just take this
immediately and uh
yeah definitely not the simplest end
game to win
but i think if you get to this point you
can sort of stop calculating and say
okay this
this is definitely a winning attempt and
not a losing attempt i have two past
pawns to my opponents one
and i can start pushing them very very
freely um
so this one a little bit more
complicated than it first seems when you
guys see this move b4
so let that be sort of a word of warning
to you guys even in these tactics
puzzles
it's very very easy to uh to go wrong to
miss something to say
easy bishop d4 and allow your opponent
this bishop f2 tactic
to uh suddenly get back into the game
why don't you stay with the white king
on e5 and just move bishop b2 to bishop
c3
well okay i mean first of all that's
that's very much a drawing attempt
uh repeating moves but
i think in the long run with like the
bishop here white can just sort of
uh come up the board right i might be
confusing whichever line you're talking
about
uh let's move along to another position
okay this one's a bit on the easier side
for you guys this is from a game
between alexandra costiniuk and
one of the polgar sisters i didn't write
down their first name i think it was
susan but it might have been judith you
never know
it might have been the third one i don't
remember her name i feel so bad
i think it was either susan or judith
though
and yeah already we do see the answer in
the chat room
like i said this one a bit on the easier
side uh
the one to turn the game around in this
case
even though white is completely down
upon here
is the move g4 and of course the thing
to notice here
is that your past pawn is more powerful
than blacks in this case why is that
well because after h3 our knight can
always come back
to defend against this pawn queening
for example h2 knight g3 and in the
meantime
black is going to have a tough time
stopping our pawn right
but now the question is you know is
white uh
is white actually winning here is white
actually winning here i feel like it's a
valid question
judit is the third one she might be the
youngest but i feel like many people
would disagree that she's the
you know the quote-unquote third one
let's go to the initial position again
because i played all of that rather
quickly
played all of that rather quickly so do
you guys agree that my line was the best
line
the other one ah of course sophia i feel
so bad apologies
to sophia pogba
as if she'll ever see this
see red panda says it's not winning in
the position i just showed it's not
winning the position
in the position that i just showed does
that mean that it's not winning here
or does that mean that there's a better
line
black should have taken g4 i'll go
through it one more time right g4
g takes h4 gh5 h3
h6 h2 he3
knight d6 h7 knight f7
and i'll i'll just tell you this
position is drawn
this position is drawn
so can white do better
ask me anything nexus
no guarantees i'll answer though
so yeah of course we should stop the h
pawn with the king
and keep the knight in our box here uh
with our knight keep the knight from uh
sort of moving
so g4 was in fact correct gh4 gh5
h3 and now white to move and win
wait to move and win king f1 or king f3
says chess king king f3 says everybody
else
be very very careful chat room be very
very careful
did you calculate did you calculate
did you guys calculate i don't think you
guys calculated
i don't think you guys calculated
of course the answer is to go king f1 as
the chat room is catching on to now
king f3 uh
i don't know if white wins the long run
or not but in the short term
black can actually catch this pawn
because you have stepped to the wrong
square my friends you have stepped to
the wrong square
so instead you have to go king g3
i think in this position and take this
guy
and yes so i mean like white's to be
preferred here because the black king is
way over here
is white winning in the long run i
honestly couldn't tell you
so king f1 is the important subtlety and
now black
is helpless to stop the pawn from
queening and
it is game over
so uh i sort of prefaced this by saying
this one was an easy one
the breakthrough of course was easy but
once again the follow-up does turn out
to be
uh rather subtle right rather rather
subtle you want to keep the knight here
to keep the knight boxed and then king
f1 over king f3 is
going to be a bit better
uh so yeah nexus it's tough to say uh
i'm sure there's there's some direct
comparisons that you can draw but
uh in general uh over-the-board chess
and online chess does tend to be
sort of radically different so you could
be much better than you would expect or
much worse than you would
would expect it's it's tough to tell
until you actually go out and uh
and just play a tournament what if g4 h
takes g4
so then unfortunately after h5 uh white
still gets this past
h pawn and black has all the same issues
with being unable to catch it
of course the king is too far away and
the knight is still in the box
but now black just gets less counter
play because this pawn is never going to
queen
with the f-pawn in the way
all right let's move on to the next
puzzle good work on that one guys
but you know learn some caution you guys
be cautious all right i have a few more
puzzles for you guys and then we'll move
on
to a real game move on to a real game
here
so once again in this position sorry let
me flip it we have
black to move and this time black is
down a piece
oh no black is just down a full piece
so clearly he must be losing right
clearly he must be must be losing
it's winning for night because for white
because because
of the bad black knight um
yes peter that that would be a fair way
to phrase it it's winning for white
because
none of the black pieces can catch the
pawn so it'd be equally fair to say
it's a winning for white because of the
bad black king or
it's it's just winning for white because
the the pawn can't be caught
so yeah here you guys are on
on the right track it does turn out that
both d3
and f3 do win the game uh d3 of course
c takes d3 e takes c3 c6 you have to
catch this pawn
uh and now let's say white
passes you go d2 and as soon as the king
steps to f3
or sorry the king steps to e2 to stop
the pawn
of course f3 check is going to be the
winning idea and after g takes f
three pawns is too many for the white
king and bishop to uh to stop together
it's just too many pawns h3 and the
game's over
uh if you start with f3
then once again i do think that uh
black is winning after g takes f of
course you have to move e3
check and the same issues now arise for
white
with stopping either of these pawns a
quick question for you guys
what's the evaluation of the position
after
it's e3 evaluation of the position after
e3
yeah you guys actually found both of
those lines really really quickly
d through the immediate c6 it doesn't
really change anything
black would still play king d6
so yeah of course this one is just going
to be a draw white can shuffle between
e2 and f3 or forever or just shuffle
with the bishop
so there you guys go but what if last
question
h3 now of course uh i'm not actually
gonna force you guys to tell me
black is actually losing can't give
white that past pawn so good job on that
one both f3 and d3 win
let's move along we have
this position this position is
what we have between uh
hualtok and kappablanca
so we have another situation here where
black does seem to be definitely favored
here
but what's the best way to actually win
this chess game
and yeah sorry let me flip it one more
time
so you guys can see
it's black to move i'm sorry it's black
to move i i'm a failure
i'm a failure at introducing puzzles
i'm not sure if e5 first is quite right
it's not what was played in the game at
least
where rook g4 was played i don't think
richie iv was played here
rook g4 loses a rook rooks are powerful
so yeah you guys have the right idea in
some order
the move h4 g takes h4
if you go g4 then takes takes takes
and all of white's pawns sort of die so
g takes h4 is necessary
then of course the breakthrough e5 is
the way
the way to go here and after fe 5 f4
and black is going to win the game with
these two connected past pawns here
and this is how black can go ahead and
break through
does e5 first work just as well
probably i think maybe it's a little bit
less forcing because uh if you do end up
going for this line
wait for the moment still has this pawn
and can maybe regroup a little bit
but i mean it should still be winning
you can also play f4 here
but you're leaving white with an extra
pawn sort of for no reason so i think h4
first is a little bit more forcing even
though e5 might still win
and uh and yeah this is how capablanca
won the game with the move
h4 followed by the idea of h5
and yeah this is just going to be
devastating the white rook can retreat
but after something like f3 for example
the king comes up and connected past
pawns are going to be enough to win
all right one more puzzle for you guy
and then i want to show for you guys and
then i want to show you
uh a position from a
real life game
so in this position
it is white to move and i'm not going to
tell you
the evaluation so white to move and you
need to figure out
if you're playing to win if you're
playing to draw
what's going on
last puzzle
what if king of six first so yeah
uh i am never gonna be able to pronounce
your name
i'm gonna go with smolinski because i
have a better chance of pronouncing your
last name
uh that position was was good enough for
black where you can play the move king
f6 first
it doesn't actually matter the idea of
h4 and e5
isn't going anywhere so really like any
move wins but the winning idea
is h4e5
draw would be easy says adi
aryan says e4 f4 knight e4
little yayo says pawn b2 to b3
upon before check
so i am curious why you guys think
white is playing for the win
why is white playing for the win
everything is better for black in this
position i think you guys might be a
little biased because i'm giving you the
puzzle with white to move
everything is better for black black's
pawns are more advanced
black's king is better than white's king
black's knight
is better than white's knight
the only thing white has going for him
is that it's his turn
the only thing white has going for him
is that it is his turn
what is the problem with 94 it hangs a
knight it hangs a knight manny
your opponent could take it like i don't
understand like i told you guys a
thousand times
you can't give me some clever way to
hang a piece you have to give me some
clever way to queen a pawn if that's
what you're trying to do
okay e4 uh captures are not forced in
chess
black has more than one option here
black has more than one option
maybe more than one good option
[Music]
manny says knight e4 f takes e4
f4 exclamation point unfortunately for
you
there are one two three four squares
remaining before you get to put a queen
on the board
and unfortunately for you your opponent
has a knight unfortunately for you
tactically you immediately lose your
pawn so i don't think knight e4 is the
way to go
i don't think it's the way to go and as
far as e4
maybe maybe white is okay
if black takes because you can uh take
back with
check and go knight f6 and take this guy
or something but
maybe maybe maybe unclear but black can
go f4
and after f4 you're pretty busted pretty
busted here fellas
pretty busted so
the correct move is actually going to be
b4 check
that's optic red panda is bringing up in
the chat this is the most forcing way
to steer the game towards a draw and
that's exactly what white is trying to
do here why it's not trying to win
like i said literally everything is
better for black about this position
everything is better for black about
this position all of his pawns are more
advanced his king's better
his pieces are better so white is trying
to draw and b4 check is a great way to
do that
if something like king to d5 then e4
check
is good i believe
um yeah e4 check if king e6 we can take
on g4
take on g4 and
we are very much fighting for a draw in
in this case even here
the draw is not going to be easy but we
can get some counter play
against the queen side pawns and
you know make a very legitimate effort
at drawing the game
make a very legitimate effort at drawing
the game also available to white
is a simple move like king d3 just
trying to sort of maintain the position
and keep black sort of at bay with all
that in mind
in the actual game this is taken from
between borgo
and lodechescu b3 was played
okay and how should black respond to b3
why not taking the pawn excellent
question
white would recapture with check and go
king b4
and it's not as if white is trying to
win here but uh
white is likely getting enough counter
play against the b5 pawn to draw
if there's something like knight c4
white probably isn't gonna take this and
give up his a pawn
but he might start trying to reroute
this knight for example
for example and once again it's it's a
tough position for white because black
is still
very much ahead but white is getting at
least some counter play here
so after b3 what should black do
what should black do remember guys that
this is a tactics puzzle
might have just not been a tactics
puzzle for white
b4 check runs into a takes b4 check
awkward awkward stuff
b4 a takes b4 king b5 yeah i mean i'll
take the a4
pawn the game still continues
so chess king brings up a really
interesting point which is
this idea of b4 would be great
if this wasn't check this wasn't check
let's say just in a miracle world our
king were on
c6 for example
and then we played b4 right and a takes
b4 happened just
let's say instead of king takes and a3
then we would have this great little
past pawn
and we would have good chances to win
this game right we can come and
take this guy and our past pawn stays
alive
our knights coming into the position and
we might win so how can we make it so
this b4 idea
works well maybe we can play knight d5
check
and after knight d5 check i know
everybody was saying 95 check
uh
the problem for white is that if he
steps to the natural square
of d3 now b4 is going to be a very very
strong move
a very very strong move because after a
takes b4
check we have knight takes counter-check
and now a3 and we have officially broken
through
and this is the great breakthrough
tactic that is going to help black win
this game
uh if white steps back to b2
then of course the issue now is that
we're not going to do this anymore which
would be a bit silly
but we are going to play king d4 and the
white king has strayed a bit
too far away same with king c2 here just
king d4
so king d3 is white's only real try but
then
the great idea of b4
to end the game uh so yeah
b4 is the breakthrough tactic that i'm
i'm ending on here
as far as tactics go and now
i want to introduce you guys to a true
tale of tragedy
this is taken from the immortal game uh
derek clasby everybody knows derek
clasby
against caleb denby who is of course a
passer of some kind and we don't care
about this part of the game because it's
an endgame class
oh look caleb's so smart he trapped a
rook in the middle of the board and now
white had to sacrifice a knight
and then we had an end game and then we
had an end game
and then we had an end game and then we
had an end game
and my question to you
of course black played like a [ __ ] here
and did not have to allow white to
advance all of his pawns up the board
but my question to you is that
should black play the simplifying move
knight f6 should black play
the simplifying move knight f6
trying to break through somehow or
after the trade is white
able to promote a pawn okay
that's my question to you guys if
it's playable black would love to
simplify the position get rid of the
white knight
and then come back to stop the pawns
comfortably but after knight f6
knight takes f6 king takes f6 is
white able to queen upon and this
is uh all the previous examples were
taken from games as well
but this one hits close to home because
maybe if i had looked at these tactics a
little bit more thoroughly
before this tournament game i might have
made the right call here
funny you ask peter peterson so some of
the positions from today
uh not all of them but some of them were
taking taken
from mastering end-game strategy by
johann
helston which uh i have not personally
read all the way through but i know
jonathan trance famous on the youtube
channel
uh highly recommends this series and
uh if you want some more great
instructional endgame contents
uh i would recommend that book even
though i haven't read
it i trust jonathan on it and it did
have some nice tactics that i
i pulled for today
well you guys are are talking in some
some
vagaries here talking very vague you're
like ah you know it's probably too far
away to stop the pawn
but that's not what the class is about
tonight the class tonight is about
tactics and game tactics
so show me the win show me the one after
knight f6 knight of 6 king f6
how does white promote a pawn
don't end your line until a pawn is a
queen
okay i'm sick of reading these lines
where it's like yeah
and then two more moves happen it's like
okay then your pawn is on b6
pawn's not on b8 yet pawn's not on b8
yet
yeah everybody's ending the line after
b6 i promise you guys
you don't get to queen until you get to
the b8 square
pawn b6 does not end the game
just give me any line to completion i'm
not
not too picky here but
you have to show me something here guys
the line doesn't end with pawn to v6
uh chess king is up to the task
and yeah chess king didn't quite end his
line
with a queen but he got close enough so
that's one of the key lines here yeah
knight f6 knight takes f6 king takes f6
of course the key move here
is c6 that's what you should start with
it's the most forcing not saying it's
the only move
for white to try but it is the most
forcing and if takes
then b6 we have to stop the pawn so
knight d8 and then after a5
king e6 a6 ah he stopped giving his line
here
but a7 a8 is rather convincing tough to
stop right
cannot be stopped but
b takes c6 is not quite forced of course
b6 is legal for black here and what can
white do
after b6
can white win after pawn to b6
stop calculating after b6 yeah but
knight d8 stops that pawn right knight
d8 stops the pawn
so yes once again a5 is the answer here
and now we are rather forced to capture
and there's no stopping the two
connected past pawns there's just no
stopping them
no stopping them at all
well i stopped them but this move is is
a bit better of course
and the line doesn't quite end here
because we have one little trick
but a queen is a queen and i think we
can even fall for the trick and still
win the game
which is just a very cruel twist of fate
isn't it
very very cruel that this would still
win the game a4 check just don't take
and then uh the game ends so of course
uh you know caleb denby being not so
good at chess
at the time i don't even know if he was
a national master maybe he was
i can't remember uh played knight f6 and
i was like yeah
c6 i'll take it he'll take me back i'll
go knight c7
uh and life is life is fine here
it's fine life is fine i'll go here it's
fine
at least a draw at least a draw
and then of course after c6 appeared on
the board i was like
oh yeah he could play b6 can't he and
uh uh the game ended in in a terrible
terrible manner
after i was up a piece for the entire
game so it can happen to me too guys it
can happen to me too
but that gives you some idea of how
these can potentially show up in your
own games
of course the the tactics that i was
showing earlier were all from games that
were
a bit uh higher class than the one
that you're seeing in front of you right
now but it it goes to show that even in
games
of you know at least my caliber
these tacks these tactics do definitely
stand a fair shot
at showing up in your games and
if i had calculated a bit better was a
bit more familiar with these tactics i
might have played a better move like
knight
8 to g7 and had a small advantage
because i am still
making threats and black is not queenie
or white is not queening by force
although likely the objective evaluation
of this position is is just to draw
is just a draw
all right well that is going to do it
for um the end game lecture here tonight
uh i know that this was a pretty wildly
different format than what i normally do
here of course
past couple lectures have been about
corresponding squares but i like
sometimes presenting just uh either
studies or or practical puzzles like
this
so let me know what you guys thought
about it hopefully you enjoyed it
it's a lot more you know stopping and
starting asking uh the chat questions
interacting
but i have a good time doing lectures
like this as well
that is going to do it for us here
tonight on the youtube channel if you
are watching live be sure to head over
to the twitch channel
for analyze your games the class where i
analyze your games uh if you're watching
the video version or you've just had
enough chess for tonight
thank you guys so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you